bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
édition de 24 heures sénat la séance
dans un instant on va parler
travailleurs détachés avec l'examen d'un
texte qui vise à lutter contre le
dumping social et la concurrence
déloyale nous avons cela voyez ce que
les sénateurs ont pensé de
l'intervention dans les médias de
françois hollande le chef de l'état qui
fait aujourd'hui les deux ans de son
quinquennat et qui tente de rebondir en
occupant le terrain de rennes ancien
président est aussi les pas aimé il faut
que les jouer de l'accordéon
un moment on veut des actes on veut du
concret on veut des réalités les
français attendent autre chose du
président républicain exercice de
communication qu'ils ont besoin de se
dire on sait où on va on sait dans quel
cadre que le temps perdu ne se rattrape
plus
je n'invite les socialistes à se
souvenir de barbara au fond on a perdu
aujourd'hui deux ans et ce report des
élections ça ressemble à une fuite en
avant est le problème avec françois
hollande c'est que quand il perd un
point de popularité il se sent obligé
d'en rajouter une couche dans la
mauvaise direction et ce matin encore
avec de nouvelles exonérations et avec
l'annoncé du report des élections
régionales et départementales
et ça commence à devenir un véritable
scandale cohérent
combatif
concentré
n'esquivant aucune aucun problème
répondant à tous
c'était à la fois une très belle
émission mais en même temps cela
démontrer un président mobilisés pour la
réussite de la fin du quinquennat la
magnus avait une politique il a essayé
de la défendre avec conviction énergie
donc ça on peut pas lui reprocher un
mais pour autant ben c'est toujours la
même politique et ça m'a pas convaincu
le salaire est bien épreuve de la france
alors vous venez de l'entendre parmi les
annonces du président de la république
c'est matin le report des scrutins
cantonaux et régionaux de 2015 à 2016
françois hollande et son gouvernement
envisage d'accélérer la réforme
territoriale qui prévoit de supprimer
les départements et de réduire le nombre
des régions la droite dénonce un
tripatouillage électoral écoutez à ce
propos le sénateur ump président du
conseil général du loiret eric doligé
alors mon rappel au règlement fait suite
à l'intervention du président de la
république ce matin sur une radio
intervention au cours de laquelle il a
parlé des régionales et des cantonales
il a parlé de la date et comme nous
sommes
l'assemblée qui s'occupe plus
particulièrement des collectivités cette
nouvelle ne peut pas passer inaperçue
d'autant plus que depuis un certain
nombre de mois nous voyons défiler en
deux ans avec 4 des lois qui se
contredisent en permanence sur le sujet
qui nous pose un certain nombre de
problèmes donc la question que je vous
pose monsieur le président si vous
pouvez leur transmettre à monsieur le
président du sénat
c'est peut-être demander un
sur le premier ministre devenir à
nouveau devant nous pour nous faire un
discours de politique d'organisation
territoriale
et la suppression des départements
pourrait d'ailleurs intervenir dès 2017
c'est une information à lire sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr jean luc
mélenchon le coprésident du parti de
gauche est l'invité de l'émission
politique de le public sénat à preuve
par trois à avoir sur notre antenne à
partir de 18 heures il a appelé les
députés abstentionnistes et ceux qui ont
rejeté le programme de stabilité de
manuel valls à le rejoindre les côtes
quand on décide de ne pas voter la
confiance à un gouvernement de refuser
son plan économique on peut pas ensuite
rentré à la maison est dit là bas on
verra la prochaine fois de quelle
manière on sera remarqué non ils doivent
eux aussi faire une proposition pose y
avait des contacts avec certains députés
ps mais si j'en ai je ne vous le dirais
pas parce que ce sont des choses qui ont
besoin disons une certaine
confidentialité pour pouvoir fonctionner
lorsque les dialogues oui pour que les
préventions sa baisse mais monsieur gros
sur j'insiste nous avons tous des
responsabilités politiques devant notre
pays ce n'est pas un jeu le pays va très
mal les gens souffrent d'une manière
inouïe par conséquent les 41 ans qui ont
dit qu'ils ne voulaient pas de cette
politique économique ont le devoir d'en
proposer une autre le groupe écologiste
du sénat a déposé une proposition de loi
pour sortir du diesel écouté les
explications d'aline archimbaud
sénatrice de seine sans mener au micro
de pauline dame
il ne s'agit pas de mettre en difficulté
les propriétaires de véhicules diesel il
s'agit de prévoir à l'avenir qu'il y
aura une taxe sur les nouveaux véhicules
diesel
pour encourager et
l'achat d'autres véhicules plus propres
je vous le disais le sénat examine cet
après midi une proposition de loi déjà
adopté par l'assemblée nationale pour
lutter contre le dumping social on va
rejoindre tout de suite thème traduit en
direct de la tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle bonjour tam bonjour delphine
alors à quoi va servir cette proposition
de loi écoutez delphine il s'agit de
sanctionner les entreprises qui ont
recours de façon abusive aux
travailleurs détachés ces travailleurs
européens qui ont la possibilité qu'ils
peuvent travailler temporairement dans
un autre pays de l'union européenne en
clair donc de lutter contre le dumping
social la concurrence déloyale et
protéger ses travailleurs car quel est
le problème c'est que théoriquement ces
travailleurs ont le salaire et les
conditions de travail de leurs pays
d'accueil la réalité aller très loin de
là c'est une main d'oeuvre bon marché
corvéables à merci et en plus de cela et
dans les entreprises payent leurs
charges sociales aux entre au pays
d'origine et en général pour ces
entreprises c'est très avantageux vous
l'avez compris delphine et bien c'est
une véritable manne pour des entreprises
peu scrupuleuses et là dessus il ya une
sorte de consensus politique pour lutter
contre ce phénomène et ses dérives
carson le phénomène va grandissant on
estime à 145 mille le nombre de
travailleurs détachés en france mais en
réalité il serait beaucoup plus nombreux
et en 13 ans leur nombre a été multiplié
par 28 merci beaucoup à un malheur sans
plus tarder on va écouter la discussion
générale de cette proposition de loi et
elle commence par l'intervention du
ministre du travail françois rebsamen
bonne séance
dans la discussion générale la parole
est un monsieur françois rebsamen
ministre du travail de l'emploi et du
dialogue social
si
je vais m'en tenir à mon département
ministériel si vous le permettez
ça nous permettra d'avancer ensemble cet
après-midi ce président ou la présidente
monsieur comme la rapporteure monsieur
sénateurs nous allons examiner donc une
proposition de loi très intéressante
celle qui était déposée par
collègues députés gilles savary qui vise
à renforcer la responsabilité des
maîtres d'ouvragé des donneurs d'ordre
dans le cadre de la sous traitance
internationale c'est un sujet qui
revient souvent parce que nous
partageons
tous un même but lutter contre le
dumping social et la concurrence
déloyale
le détachement des travailleurs
étrangers n'est pas un fait nouveau
mais il se développe ces détachements
concerné 1
670 mille salariés en 2012 et on peut
les évaluer on n'a pas encore les
chiffres précis mais on peut lire
évaluée à 220 me de salariés en 2013
soit une hausse importante de l'ordre de
10% un grand nombre de nos compatriotes
en bénéficient également je voudrais
l'indiqué car en effet 140 mille
français sont détachés à l'étranger par
des entreprises françaises la france est
le troisième pays en europe à user de
cette possibilité le principe même du
détachement des travailleurs n'est pas
en cause il faut le rappeler ce qui est
en cause ce sont les montages frauduleux
et les abus qui peuvent l'entourer
et qui malheureusement et nous le savons
se développe de plus en plus la
directive européenne
de 1996 la directive détachement avait
posé un cadre
je crois qu'ils étaient pertinents aucun
employeur établi hors d'un territoire ne
peut mettons le présent ne peut détacher
un salarié sans être soumis sans être
soumis aux règles respect des règles
sociales de l'état d'accueil mais force
est de constater qu'aujourd'hui cette
même directive elle est contournée nous
le savons sans possibilité réelle de
sanctions ces situations d'ailleurs ne
sont ni l'apanage des villes ni celui
des campagnes ni celui d'ailleurs des
chantiers du bâtiment au public de btp
ou des exploitations agricoles c'est en
réalité un sujet pour toute la société
française moi je vais le même le dire
pour toute l'europe et donc pour le
gouvernement pour nous je le pense pour
vous aussi le choix est clair faire
l'europe construire l'europe ce n'est
pas laissée faire et nous nous devons de
refuser la concurrence une sorte de
moins disant social
c'est tout l'intérêt d'ailleurs de cette
proposition de loi elle protège les
entreprises qui elles payent leurs
cotisations sociales en france et
respecte le droit elle protège les
travailleurs installé en france aussi
d'une concurrence comme on pourrait en
dire idées gagnent aussi inégal réagi
mais elle protège elle a aussi cette
fonction elle protège les travailleurs
détachés qui sont pas coupables comme
d'habitude mais qui sont victimes
eux-mêmes de ces pratiques inacceptables
et donc crois que c'est l'honneur de
notre pays que de protéger de respecter
et de protéger ceux qui travaillent sur
le sol français et pour tous les
travailleurs détachés ou pas la loi
française est la même et elle doit
s'appliquer il est donc il légal en
france par exemple de travailler 45
heures par semaine pour 3 euros de
l'heure ou moins de dormir dans des
hangars heureusement et de ne pas avoir
droit accès aux soins ces dénis ces
contournements de notre droit provoque
cette concurrence déloyale que dénoncent
d'une même voix on peut le dire
organisations syndicales et patronales
et qui engendre il faut bien le
reconnaître ici ou là racisme et
xénophobie
en 2012 la commission européenne a
proposé un texte
simple en moi je le dis comme je le
pense à textes faible un texte faible
qui ne donne pas la possibilité
de demander des comptes ne demander de
rendre des comptes aux donneurs d'ordres
le vrai responsable
la france l'a refusée c'est à son
honneur le 25 octobre dernier faisant
ainsi échouer comme quoi cela peut
arriver un mauvais compromis et se
donnant deux mois pour convaincre
nos partenaires européens avec
l'allemagne mais aussi avec la roumanie
avec la bulgarie qui savent mieux que
quiconque ce que veut dire
d'exploitation de leurs travailleurs
nous y sommes parvenus et je crois que
le compromis qui a été arraché le 9
décembre 2013 est un bon compromis
deux mots pour dépeindre ce compromis il
comporte incontestablement deux avancées
majeures
premièrement que la liste des documents
exigibles auprès des entreprises en cas
de contrôle soit une liste ouverte la
france fixera la liste des documents
exigibles pour tous les travailleurs
détachés dans notre pays en france la
directive imposera aussi des règles dans
les pays qui en sont aujourd'hui
dépourvues fort dépourvu
deuxièmement que les entreprises
donneuses d'ordre du secteur du bâtiment
et des travaux publics j'ai rencontré
les responsables des fédérations du
bâtiment des travaux publics bien sûr
que les entreprises soient
responsabilisées me l'avait demandé
vis-à-vis de leurs sous traitants
obligatoirement et dans tous les états
sous la forme d'une responsabilité
solidaire ou alors d'un mécanisme de
sanction équivalente en clair qu'est ce
que ça veut dire qui sera désormais
possible je crois d'établir une chaîne
de responsabilités pour lutter contre
des montages qui sont des montages
frauduleux
et qui n'ont qu'un seul but c'est de
contourner la loi et les textes donc on
peut le dire elle a fait beaucoup jaser
la page de la directive bolkenstein est
donc bel et bien tournée il n'y aura
plus ni dumping ni exploitation
je voudrais également rappeler que c'est
le parlement européen moment
quelque temps des élections européennes
qui a voté cette directive le 16 avril
dernier
on entend dire tellement mal qu il est
temps de rappeler quand des choses se
font sur la pression bien sûr en
l'occurrence de notre de notre pays la
proposition de loi que nous étudions
aujourd'hui seuls donc de notre collègue
gilles savary votre collègue excusez moi
gilles savary anticipe sa mise en oeuvre
va au devant de cette mise en oeuvre et
la renforce elle ne limite pas son champ
d'action au seul secteur du bâtiment on
sait que c'est un des secteurs qui
allaient plus touchés mais elle ne
limite pas le champ d'action au seul
secteur du bâtiment elle élargit la
chaîne de responsabilités à l'ensemble
et c'est très important à l'ensemble des
donneurs d'ordre des maîtres d ouvrage
mais aussi parce qu'ils sont impliqués
dans cette chaîne des entreprises de
travail temporaire ou bien tout
simplement des entreprises qui
sous-traitent et elle garantit cette
proposition de loi elle garantit ainsi
aux salariés la souci légitime aux
salariés détachés la possibilité
vis-à-vis de leur employeur de faire
valoir leurs droits elle confère en
outre nous aurons l'occasion de le voir
aux organisations syndicales la
possibilité d'agir au nom d'un salarié
lorsque celui ci par exemple n'est plus
présent sur le territoire ce qui est
bien souvent le cas votre commission
commission que vous présidez madame sous
l'égide de madame emery dumas rapporteur
a fait un important travail de
simplification de la proposition et je
voudrais ici vous en remercier parce que
il est important d'aller vers des textes
simples efficaces précis et qui puisse
réellement à s'appliquer jeu mais là je
les en remercie monsieur le sénateur ces
propositions permettent d'en renforcer
d'ailleurs la porte et en articulant on
peut dire les mesures autour de deux
axes premièrement la création
sanctions administratives pour
non-respect de l'obligation de
déclaration de l'entreprise non respect
de l'obligation de déclaration de
l'entreprise mais aussi
l'obligation de vigilance nécessaire
indispensable du donneur d'ordres lui
même responsabiliser qui doit être
assise responsabiliser et qui doit
vérifier que l'entreprise à laquelle il
fait appel est en règle et puis deuxième
axe le recentrage de la solidarité
financière en cas de non respect de son
obligation de diligence pour par exemple
non paiement des salariés par leur
employeur ou ça arrive malheureusement
encore trop souvent pour hébergement
dans des conditions particulièrement
indigne
les donneurs d'ordre qui dans notre pays
en france
ne se seront pas assurés du respect de
ses obligations par leurs prestataires
donc vous voyez la chaîne comment ces
faits seront donc également passibles de
sanctions parallèlement la
responsabilité solidaire du donneur
d'ordres a été recentré sur le paiement
par l'entreprise de celle de salaire
qu'il ya des amendements sur ce sujet
inférieur au minima conventionnels ou
légaux et ou sur la prise en charge du
relogement collectif des salariés
l'action là messieurs les sénateurs ne
s'arrête pas là le plan national de
lutte contre le travail illégal apporte
également des outils supplémentaires
ces outils supplémentaires c'est
s'institue par exemple où se place dans
le cadre de la réforme de l'inspection
du travail qui crée des unités
pluridisciplinaire et spécialisés
d'indispensables
l'urssaf forces de l'ordre les forces de
l'ordre et où les services fiscaux
peut-être même services douaniers sont
également impliqués dans cette lutte
avec la volonté d'une plus grande
cohérence de l'action collective
c'est la décision dans notre pays dans
d'autres pays dès qu'un chantier s'ouvre
la police arrive pour vérifier la
réalité des des salariés des entreprises
et les conditions légales de leur emploi
nous ne sommes pas là mais nous mettons
en place des dispositifs efficaces pour
vérifier cela sans harmonisation des
conditions sociales en europe on peut le
dire les libertés de circulation du
commerce tout ce qui a été mis dans nos
traités vont devenir caduque des choses
clairement et risquent d'être rangé à
terme par le dumping et donc le
gouvernement apporte mais la mission au
sénateur son soutien plein et entier à
cette profession de loi afin de mieux
combattre
de dissuader et éventuellement de
sanctionner les abus à la veille des
élections européennes je les dis ce
texte montre quelle europe nous voulons
nous la gauche moi je le dis en tous les
cas nous voulons une europe solidaire
nous voulons une europe des échanges du
partage de la libre circulation mais
aussi dans ce cadre la gelée d'hier à
mon collègue britannique une europe
respectueuse des règles sans lesquels le
vivre ensemble des nations à l'intérieur
du concert européen deviendra impossible
je vous en remercie je vous remercie
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à madame anna emery dumars
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales en dhr
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente
mes chers collègues la proposition de
loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui a été
adoptée le 25 février dernier par
l'assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée
rebaptisé la semaine dernière en
commission elle vise désormais à lutter
contre les fraudes et les abus constatés
lors des détachements de travailleurs et
contre la concurrence déloyale
ce sujet n'est pas inconnu de notre
assemblée puisqu'elle a adopté en séance
publique le 16 octobre dernier à l'issue
d'un débat de qualité une résolution sur
les normes européennes en matière de
détachement des travailleurs à
l'unanimité des présents
cette résolution apporter le soutien du
sénat au gouvernement français engagés
alors dans une négociation difficile
avec nos partenaires européens au sujet
de la directive d'exécution de la
directive 96 71 concernant le dire le
détachement de travailleurs dans le
cadre d'une prestation de service
je voudrais à cette occasion salué le
travail remarquable de la commission des
affaires européennes du sénat et plus
particulièrement de son rapporteur éric
bocquet qui est présent ici dont le
rapport d'information du 18 avril 2013 a
permis de poser les jalons de la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui
ce travail précurseur ensuite été repris
et approfondie par nos collègues députés
à travers le rapport d'information du 29
mai 2013 de gilles savary chantal guy
tmi sel et michel piron également
assortie d'une proposition de résolution
européenne qui a été adopté
définitivement le 11 juillet dernier
compte tenu de l'ampleur du travail
parlementaire sur cette question et de
l'intervention que vient de faire
monsieur le ministre je me contenterai
par conséquent d'une rapide présentation
des enjeux économiques sociaux et
humains que représentent les abus et les
fraudes au détachement
liée à la libre prestation de services
qui est inscrite au coeur de la
construction européenne le détachement
de travailleurs connaît une progression
exponentielle
selon la direction générale du travail
de 110 mille salariés ont été détachés
en 2013 en france ce qui représente
compte tenu d'une durée moyenne de
prestations de 44 jours l'équivalent de
33000 équivalent temps plein sur une
année le nombre de salariés détachés a
ainsi été multiplié par 28 ans 13 années
en plus de ces travailleurs déclarés
auprès de l'inspection du travail il
faut compter tous ceux qui ne le sont
pas même si la dgt a depuis abandonné
son estimation à la considérer en 2009
et en 2010 qu'un salarié détaché sur
deux à un salarié sur trois n'étaient
pas déclarés on distingue
schématiquement deux catégories de
fraude et d'abus la première catégorie
regroupe les fraudes et abus spécifique
à la réglementation du détachement comme
vous le savez les règles du détachement
s'applique aux personnes qui exécutent
leur travail pendant une période limitée
sur le territoire d'un état membre autre
que l'état sur le territoire duquel elle
travaille habituellement or le
prestataire étranger n'est parfois
qu'une coquille vide sans activité
stable continue et permanente dans
l'état d'origine ce qui est un
contournement de du détachement
par ailleurs les salariés sont parfois
recrutés exclusivement pour la période
du pour la période et la durée du
détachement
et surtout les droits garantis par ce
que l'on appelle le noyau dur ne sont
pas toujours respectées par exemple en
matière de paiement du salaire minimum
en vigueur dans le pays d'accueil en
matière de conditions d'hygiène et de
sécurité de repos et de congés
même s'il faut éviter tout amalgame
entre détachement de travailleurs et
travail illégal force est de constater
que l'absence de déclaration préalable
de détachement auprès de l'inspection du
travail s'accompagne souvent d'un délit
de travail dissimulé
les délit de marchandage et de prêt de
main d'oeuvre illicite sont quant à eux
moins fréquent mais non moins grave
cette seconde catégorie de fraude est
difficile à déceler car les montages
juridiques sont souvent complexes et
font appel à plusieurs pays quelquefois
également à des à des pays tiers comme
intermédiaire il y a donc urgence à agir
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
pour protéger les droits des
travailleurs détachés tout d'abord qui
sont souvent démunis en position de
faiblesse sur notre territoire et disons
le mot exploiter et pour mettre fin au
développement croissant d'une
concurrence déloyale à l'égard des
entreprises françaises qui respectent la
loi et plus que plus globalement
également pour préserver notre modèle
social mise à mal par des entreprises
qui ne paient pas leurs cotisations
tel est le sens de cette proposition de
loi qui a été considérablement enrichie
lors de son examen en commission et en
séance à l'assemblée nationale
le plus souvent à l'instigation de son
rapporteur gilles savary dont la
compétence l'engagement et le sens de l'
écoute ne sont plus à démontrer
le texte ne se limite pas à transposer
les articles 9 et 12 de la directive
d'exécution adopté le 16 avril dernier
par le parlement européen et qui portent
respectivement sur les mesures de
contrôle du détachement que peut
instituer un état membre et sur la
solidarité financière du donneur
d'ordres à l'égard du salaire minimum
des salariés détachés d'un sous traitant
il met également en oeuvre certaines
préconisations de la résolution
européenne de l'assemblée nationale du
11 juillet dernier comme la création
d'une liste loi d'une liste noire
excusez-moi d'entreprises et de
prestataires des services indélicat ou
la possibilité pour les syndicats
d'ester en justice pour défendre les
droits des salariés détachés
par ailleurs le texte renforce notre
arsenal juridique de lutte contre le
travail illégal en conférant par exemple
de nouvelles prérogatives aux agents de
contrôle aux juges et aux autorités
administratives
enfin il prévoit diverses mesures pour
mieux encadrer le cabotage routier de
marchandises
venons en aux modifications qui ont été
apportées au texte par la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat
nous ne pouvons bien entendu que
partager la philosophie des auteurs de
la proposition de loi mais suite à la
vingtaine d'auditions que j'ai menée le
mois dernier j'ai acquis la conviction
qu'il fallait simplifier les règles si
on voulait atteindre l'objectif de faire
diminuer les fraudes et abus éviter les
stratégies de contournement de la part
des entreprises et faciliter le travail
des agents de contrôle et je me félicite
de constater que la commission a bien
voulu amant adopté les amendements que
j'ai proposé en ce sens
en premier lieu la commission a souhaité
traiter à part entière la question de la
déclaration préalable de détachement qui
est au coeur du débat sans la lier à la
question de la solidarité financière en
cas de non paiement des salariés
détachés comme le faisait l'article 1er
de la proposition de loi sortie de
l'assemblée nationale nous avons tout
d'abord élever au niveau législatif
l'obligation pour le prestataire
étranger d'effectuer une déclaration
préalable de détachement auprès de
l'inspection du travail
outre cette déclaration l'employeur
devra indiquer les coordonnées de son
représentant en france conformément à
l'article 9 de la directive d'exécution
qui autorise les états membres à imposer
la désignation d'une personne je cite
chargé d'assurer la liaison avec les
autorités compétentes dans l'état membre
d'accueil dans lequel les services sont
fournis
nous avons ensuite fait obligation aux
donneurs d'ordre ou aux maîtres
d'ouvragé qui recourt à un prestataire
étranger de vérifier que celui ci s'est
bien acquitté de son obligation de
déclaration quel que soit le montant de
la prestation
les particuliers sont toutefois
dispensée de cette obligation de
vigilance à l'instar de ce qui était
déjà prévu dans la proposition de loi
initiale
et surtout la commission a franchi un
pas décisif en prévoyant que tout
manquement à ses règles de la part du
prestataire étranger mais aussi du
donneur d'ordre ou du maître d'ouvragé
français dans sa relation avec un
cocontractant étrangers sera passible
d'une sanction administrative
la situation actuelle n'est pas
satisfaisante chacun en conviendra
l'amande contraventionnelle de 4e classe
et peu dissuasives 750 euros et elle est
rarement appliquée d'où la proposition
de créer une sanction administrative
prononcée par le directeur de la
direccte en nous inspirant largement de
celles prévues à l'article 1er de la
proposition de loi tendant au
développement à l'encadrement des stages
et à l'amélioration du statut des
stagiaires que le sénat examine
actuellement et même directement après
notre texte
le montant de l'amendé sera au plus de
2000 euros par salarié détaché et aux
plus de 4000 euros en cas de réitération
dans un délai d'un an à compter du jour
de la notification de la première amende
le tout étant plafonnée à 10000 euros
pour fixer son montant l'autorité
administrative devra prendre en compte
les circonstances et la gravité du
manquement le comportement de son auteur
ainsi que ses ressources et ses charges
ce qui permettra de la souplesse
en outre la commission a supprimé la
création d'une déclaration spécifique en
cas de sous traitance imposé aux maîtres
d'ouvragé ou donneurs d'ordre car celle
ci devenait superfétatoire du fait de
l'obligation générale de vérification
imposer au donneur d'ordre ou maître
d'ouvragé dès le premier euro
en deuxième lieu la commission a retenu
un dispositif unique de solidarité
financière applicables aux donneurs
d'ordres et aux maîtres d'ouvragé en cas
de non paiement du salaire minimum un
salarié d'un sous-traitant qu'ils soient
détachées ou non le dispositif prévu à
l'article 1er qui ne concernait que les
salariés détachés a donc été supprimée
par souci de simplicité
la commission a en outre élargi le champ
d'application de la solidarité
financière prévue à l'article 2 d'une
part les personnes qui recourent aux
services d'une entreprise de travail
temporaire pourront désormais être mises
à contribution
tandis que la protection de la
solidarité financière s'étendra aussi
aux salariés du cocontractant des sous
traitants
en troisième mieux
la commission a procédé à divers
aménagements pour renforcer la cohérence
du texte elle a tout d'abord sécuriser
juridiquement les dispositions relatives
à l'action en justice d'un syndicat pour
défendre les droits des salariés
détachés sans mandat de sa part la
commission a aligné les dispositions
d'expression de l'opposition du salarié
sur celles qui existent déjà dans notre
code du travail en matière notamment de
marchandage de discrimination ou de
harcèlement par exemple elle a ensuite
prévu une amende de 3750 euros et un
emprisonnement de deux mois lorsqu'une
personne qui a fait l'objet d'un procès
verbal pour travail illégal ne respecte
pas une décision administrative de
remboursement dettes publiques
enfin la commission a étendu la
possibilité donnée au juge de prononcer
à titre de peine complémentaire
lorsqu'une personne est condamné pour
travail illégal l'interdiction de
recevoir une aide publique aux aides
financières versées par une personne
privée chargée d'une mission de service
public dans le cadre bien évidemment de
cette mission de service public il
s'agissait pour la commission d'un
amendement de cohérence juridique
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
vous constaterez comme moi que la
commission a amélioré le texte sur des
points décisifs qui devrait recueillir
une large approbation sur ses bancs le
texte au final nous paraît conforme aux
dispositions de la directive d'exécution
et aux principes constitutionnels tout
en apportant des réponses pratiques aux
attentes des entreprises des salariés et
aux attentes des agents de contrôle
avant de conclure je voudrais présenter
les conditions nécessaires à la réussite
des objectifs de cette proposition de
loi aussi bien au niveau européen qu'au
niveau national
sur la scène européenne notre pays doit
de tout d'abord oeuvré en faveur d'une
harmonisation sociale par le haut le
débat que nous avons eu la semaine
dernière en commission en témoigne la
concurrence restera déloyale tant que
les niveaux de cotisations sociales
entre états membres resteront aussi
hétérogène
compte tenu du différentiel de
cotisations sociales et de l'obligation
pour un salarié détaché pendant moins de
deux de continuer de payer ses
cotisations à la sécurité sociale de son
pays d'origine le coût horaire net d'un
ouvrier polonais par exemple est de 20 à
30% plus bas que celui de son homologue
français la convergence économique entre
états membres et entre régimes de
sécurité sociale est inéluctable 10 les
plus optimistes certes mais à quelle
échéance il n'empêche notre gouvernement
doit être une forte ce motrices en
europe pour faire bouger les lignes
en attendant et dans le respect de la
réglementation européenne qui s'imposent
à nous il nous faut renchérir le coût
des détachements car ce différentiel de
20 à 30% sera sensiblement amoindri si
le prestataire étranger doit supporter
l'intégralité des frais de transport et
les frais d'hébergement de ses salariés
détachés il faudra également aller vers
une carte d'affiliation à la sécurité
sociale au niveau européen ainsi qu'une
déclaration européenne de détachement
afin de faciliter les contrôles et de
lutter contre les fraudes
transnationales
par ailleurs s'agissant des conditions
de travail dans les transports européens
la commission des affaires européennes
du sénat et son rapporteur éric bocquet
ont rendu le 10 avril dernier un rapport
d'information très complet et documenté
assortie d'une proposition de résolution
qui contient des pistes de réflexion qui
mériteront d'être approfondie ainsi dans
le transport routier de marchandises la
commission préconise la mise en place
rapide du chronotachygraphe intelligent
dès 2018 dans tous les véhicules de
transport par route et sa diffusion
rapide dans les corps de contrôle ainsi
que l'introduction d'un carnet européen
de cabotage pour chaque véhicule de
transport
au niveau français la coopération entre
les différents agents de contrôle doit
être renforcée et facilité
faute de quoi les dispositions de la loi
resteront resteront lettre morte il ne
s'agit pas de se donner bonne conscience
en instaurant des normes ambitieuses que
dans la réalité nous ne pourrons décliné
sur le terrain faire vivre au quotidien
en suscitant au final la frustration et
la déception de ce point de vue le
travail des corps de contrôle sera
grandement facilitée
et par la mise en oeuvre de
l'application cipsi systèmes
d'information prestations de service
international qui centralisera toutes
les déclarations de détachement et
pourra être consulté notamment par les
contrôleurs de l'urssaf
le gouvernement doit également
poursuivre la réforme en cours de
l'inspection du travail qui est en
première ligne pour détecter les abus et
les fraudes au détachement et lutter
contre le travail illégal
les inspecteurs et contrôleurs du
travail ne peuvent pas se désintéresser
de cette lutte car les délits du droit
du travail saf les sape les fondements
même du droit du travail qui peut
accepter sur le territoire de la
république des conditions de travail et
d'hébergement incompatibles avec la
dignité humaine
encore faut-il que leurs effectifs leur
mission et leur formation soit à la
hauteur de nos ambitions
c'est pourquoi j'apporte tout mon
soutien au plan national de lutte contre
le travail illégal ainsi qu'à la réforme
qui vise à faire du ministère du travail
un ministère fort que votre prédécesseur
monsieur le ministre a engagé dès son
arrivée aux responsabilités et dont je
ne doute pas que vous allez là continue
et
en aval des contrôles la réponse pénale
doit être amélioré et complété par le
développement des sanctions
administratives que j'appelle de mes
voeux pour sanctionner rapidement les
infractions non délictuel et désengorger
les tribunaux tout en respectant tout en
respectant le principe du contradictoire
et les droits des employeurs tel est
précisément l'ambition de l'accent la
sanction administrative que nous avons
créée pour renforcer l'effectivité des
déclarations préalables de détachement
enfin les décisions administratives
prises à l'encontre dès personnes
verbalisées pour travail illégal doivent
être encouragés car elle constitue un
instrument riche de promesses au sein de
notre arsenal juridique
malheureusement selon les indications
provisoires fournies par la délégation
nationale à la lutte contre la fraude
seuls trois décisions de refus d'être
publics ont été formulées l'an dernier
et une décision d'exclusion temporaire
des marchés publics il convient par
conséquent d'identifier rapidement les
obstacles qui freinent le développement
de ces décisions et d'y remédier en
conclusion mes chers collègues je ne
peux que vous inviter à adopter cette
proposition de loi issue d'un travail
approfondi du parlement et souhaite
qu'elle recueille l'assentiment du plus
large possible sur ces bancs et je vous
remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur jean désessard
pour le groupe écologie
monsieur le président je suis ministre
du travail de l'emploi et du dialogue
social
même la reporter madame la présidente de
la commission chers collègues
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui prévoit un certain nombre de
mesures pour lutter plus efficacement
contre les abus dans le domaine du
détachement des travailleurs
alors monsieur le ministre vous verrez
dans mon
intervention que je dis beaucoup de
choses que vous avez plus ou moins dit
voilà il ya une convergence monsieur le
ministre voilà j'espère que la france
est un pays qui accueille de plus en
plus de salariés détachés 38 milan 2606
il en 2009 210 milles en 2013 les
travailleurs détachés présent france
sont principalement originaires la
pologne du portugal et de la roumanie la
durée du détachement total a progressé
d'un tiers entre 2012 et 2013 passant de
5,7 millions de jours détaché à 7,6
millions la durée moyenne du détachement
et de 45 jours et les secteurs les plus
concernés sont le btp et les agences de
travail temporaire
mais
les travailleurs français sont également
nombreux est détaché j'ai pas exactement
le même nombre que vous monsieur le
ministre puisque je vais dire 169000 en
2011 mais je suppose qu'on parle pas de
la même année vous avez des chiffres
certainement plus actualisé avec comme
pays d'accueil principaux pour les
français d'état c'est la belgique
l'allemagne et l'italie est comme vous
monsieur le ministre je considère que ce
n'est pas le détachement en lui même qui
pose problème dans une europe ouverte
les personnes doivent pouvoir circuler
librement ce qui pose problème ce sont
les conditions dans lesquelles ces
travailleurs sont accueillis et dans ce
domaine les fraudes et les abus sont
loin d'être négligeables comme cela a
été dit en france le taux de déclaration
détachement est compris entre 33 et 50 %
c'est peu
et l'estimation des détachements non
déclarés donc en situation régulière est
de 200 à 300 mille personnes les
conditions d'accueil et d'hébergement
sont parfois indignes sans parler des
rythmes de travail que certains
employeurs inflige à ses travailleurs
détachés
ainsi le sujet dont nous traitons
aujourd'hui après au respect de la
dignité humaine
le législateur doit mettre un terme à
des conditions d'exploitation d'un autre
âge auquel sont soumis certains
travailleurs étrangers
la présente proposition de loi définit
dans cette optique une série de règles
et de procédures visant à
responsabiliser les entreprises ayant
recours à des travailleurs détachés et
je vais répéter
certaines analyses que vous avez
développé madame le rapporteur mais ce
sont des points importants et je vais
appliquer la méthode dite du marteau
c'est à dire bien répéter pour bien
enfoncer le clou le coeur du dispositif
concerne la responsabilité solidaire du
donneur d'ordre celle ci est étendue aux
salaires aux conditions de vie des
travailleurs aux libertés fondamentales
et et à tous les aspects du droit du
travail
les donneurs d'ordres devront également
vérifier que leurs prestataires a bien
effectué les démarches de déclaration
préalable de détachement alors c'est
important parce qu'il peut y aura une
petite société qui emploie des gens dans
des conditions
indignes
là ce qu'on lui demande des comptes elle
n'existe plus alors que le donneur
d'ordres est souvent une grande société
cap union sur rue et qui peut rendre des
comptes donc cette disposition est
fondamentale
désormais les entreprises qui ont
recours à des travailleurs étrangers aux
intrants genot pourront plus dire nous
ne savions pas elles sont tenus pour
responsables afin d'assurer des
conditions d'accueil et de travail
décentes pour tous ces travailleurs
le texte prévoit aussi une avancée
notable par le biais de la liste noire
ils seront inscrits les noms et les
coordonnées des prestataires de services
condamné pour des infractions
infractions consécutive le travail
illégal
le rôle de la société civile est
également accrue en permettant aux
syndicats d'attaqué des employeurs en
justice et ce même sans mandat de
travailleurs concernés s est important
il s'agit là d'une avancée notable en
effet lorsque des conditions de travail
déplorables font l'objet d'une attention
de la part des médias des syndicats ou
de l'administration les travailleurs
concernés
sont souvent face à des pressions voire
des menaces pour garder le silence aussi
avec cette mesure les principaux
intéressés ne rompt pas se mettre en
danger pour que leurs droits soient
respectés puisque c'est le syndicat qui
pourra te garantit des périodes de repos
pour les conducteurs ok suspension des
aides publiques en cas de condamnation
inscription des déclarations de recours
aux travailleurs détachés dans le
registre unique du personnel toutes ces
autres mesures vont dans le bon sens
alors je me permettrait d'élargir le
débat car si cette proposition de loi
permet de lutter contre les fraudes et
les abus constatés leur détachement de
travailleurs qu'en est il de la lutte
contre la concurrence déloyale
et du dumping social nous nous efforçons
de limiter les effets négatifs sont
ouvrir le débat sur les courses or ce
qui pose aujourd'hui les employeurs
avoir recours à une main d'oeuvre bon
marché low cost diront les anglicistes
c'est la dérégulation forcené du monde
de travail qui touche actuellement tous
les pays d'europe et en particulier des
plus fragiles une des raisons de ce
recours massif au détachement s'explique
par les différences importantes qui
subsistent entre les différents systèmes
sociaux en europe à titre d'exemple dans
le secteur du btp si les cotisations
patronales s'élève à plus de 50% en
france pour des ouvriers peu qualifiés
elle ne se chiffre qu'à 20% apolloni cet
écart très important est une source
d'économie pour les employeurs car
concernant la filiation régime de
sécurité sociale c'est le maintien
du régime du pays d'origine qui prévaut
ainsi certains pays deviennent de
véritables aubaines pour les employeurs
soucieux de réduire les coûts de
personnel le seul moyen d'enrayer ce
phénomène est de procéder sans plus
tarder à une coordination à une
harmonisation des systèmes sociaux en
europe une harmonisation pour favoriser
ou sauvegarde et la protection sociale
en europe cette harmonisation doit être
accompagnée par l'émergence d'une
organisation européenne du travail et
d'une coopération syndicale européenne
pour garantir efficacement la défense de
travailleurs quel que soit leur pays
d'origine alors dans la tente de ce
débat plus que jamais nécessaire la
veille des élections européennes et
considérons des avancées concrètes
contenu la présente proposition de loi
les écologistes voteront pour ce texte
et écologistes nous savons que l'europe
être notre horizon politique de demain
mais c'est à nous de construire cette
europe sociale cette europe solidaire
qui sera la calant la garantie de la
dignité pour tous les travailleurs je
vous remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur jean bizet pour
le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers mentionnera madame le
rapporteur pardon chers collègues au
risque de créer la surprise
je vais entamer mon intervention par un
compliment
mais attention ça ne va pas durer
je pense tout simplement
savourer le cas même que cette
proposition de loi est plutôt la
bienvenue
bien que les différents pays de l'union
européenne est tantôt été bénéficiaire
est victime du dumping social et de la
concurrence déloyale
ces derniers sont aujourd'hui
majoritairement favorables à une
meilleure régulation du marché du
travail européen
le droit de prêter librement des
services droit qui a été consacré par
l'article 49 du traité de rome connaît
en effet des abus manifestes
par prudence ne rentrerai pas dans les
débats que semble esquisser l'exposé des
motifs de la présente proposition de loi
les auteurs du texte estiment que c'est
la conjonction de la directive relative
aux services dans le marché intérieur
directive bolkenstein et la directive
relative au détachement de travailleurs
effectuée dans le cadre d'une prestation
de service dit détachement dite
directive détachement qui a laissé la
porte ouverte à des fraudes et à des
détournements massifs
vous comprendrez qu'une démonstration
contraire serait hasardeuse je souscris
donc à ce postulat de départ j'ajouterai
simplement que la mauvaise application
de ces directives ne doit pas servir à
alimenter une quelconque hostilité à
l'égard du droit de prester librement
des services hostilités pourtant
grandissante aujourd'hui est que sur
tous les bancs ici nous devons dénoncer
je le dis donc sans crainte il existe
aujourd'hui un phénomène de détournement
de contournement
j'allais dire de retournement non
choisies sont bien nos maux de
contournement des directives mais il
serait malhonnête de croire que le
phénomène des salariés low cost commence
et s'arrête avec les initiatives
communautaires
comme le dit très justement l'exposé des
motifs de cette proposition de loi il
exige un phénomène de fraude massifs
qui se développe en dehors de tout cadre
légal et donc soulignons le en dehors
des directives paul beulque einstein et
des directives détachement en d'autres
termes ne dénigrons pas les outils même
insuffisant qui ont été mis en place car
ce sont ces outils qui nous permettront
de résoudre pour une large part le
problème des salariés low cost car c'est
une chose et c'est une chose qu'on
oublie trop souvent les travailleurs
détachés ne sont que la partie émergée
de l'iceberg
on en compte deux cent dix mille en
france pour plus de 300 milles en
allemagne où près de 150 milles en
belgique mais quid de ceux qui ne sont
pas inscrits les estimations ne nous
permettent pas aujourd'hui d'appréhender
le phénomène avec précision chose est
sûre après avoir plus ou moins fermé les
yeux les pays européens sont en train de
prendre la mesure du problème
certaines économies se sont en effet
longtemps satisfaite de cet afflux de
main d'oeuvre bon marché pour exécuter
des tâches à faible valeur ajoutée mais
de fait ceux qui croyaient l'utilisation
des travailleurs détachés que
l'utilisation des travailleurs détachés
pouvait améliorer la compétitivité de
leurs économies se sont trompés d'abord
parce que les secteurs concernés ne sont
pas délocalisables l'exception des
transports ensuite comme le cas allemand
le montrer le démontre chaque jour les
excédents commerciaux commerciaux sont
d'abord le fruit d'une meilleure
compétitivité en conflit
aujourd'hui la prise de conscience et
donc générale la commission européenne
n'y échappe pas puisque celle ci a
présenté le 21 mars 2012 une proposition
de directive d'application de la
directive dans une même démarche
rappelons l'utilisation du système
d'information du marché intérieur limite
pour la coopération administrative entre
états membres prévus par le règlement du
25 octobre 2012 le parlement a poursuivi
les travaux avec le vote de la
commission de l'emploi du parlement
européen le vin
juin 2013 visant à entamer les
négociations avec le conseil et enfin le
9 décembre 2013 un accord sur une
orientation générale a été conclu lors
de la réunion du conseil emploi et
affaires sociales
le groupe ump n'est donc pas hostile par
principe à une proposition de loi qui
cherche à accélérer un processus déjà
bien avancé mais qui ne devrait
s'achever qu'à compter de 2016 là où
votre proposition de loi va nous poser
des difficultés c'est dans son opération
habilité
l'article 2 instaure la responsabilité
solidaire du donneur d'ordre en cas de
non paiement des salaires des
travailleurs détachés par un
sous-traitant directe ou indirecte
là nous vous rejoignons
malheureusement pourquoi étendre le
dispositif de responsabilité solidaire à
l'ensemble du noyau d'obligations de
l'employeur qui détache des travailleurs
cette disposition va consacrer une forme
d'ingérence du donneur d'ordres à
l'égard des sous traitants
par principe nous pouvons souscrire à
une telle extension de la responsabilité
solidaire de plus comment les donneurs
d'ordres pourront concrètement procéder
aux vérifications qui leur incombent
cette difficulté est d'autant plus
regrettable que l'article 2 sur la
responsabilité solidaire a vu sa
rédaction considérablement amélioré à
l'issue de sa première lecture à
l'assemblée en ce qui concerne la mise
en place d'une liste noire d'entreprises
indélicate en matière de travailleurs
détachés nous nous interrogeons sur
l'efficacité de la mesure en effet le
caractère coercitif de celle ci nous
échappe puisque il nous semble qu'elle
sera sans conséquences pour les
entreprises concernées notamment en
termes d'accès aux marchés publics
crayon que ce soit simplement un
affichage plus surprenant encore elle
n'empêchera pas les donneurs d'ordre ou
les maîtres d'ouvragé de contracter avec
les entreprises qui seraient inscrites
toujours dans le même esprit l'article 7
donne la possibilité pour les syndicats
de se constituer partie civile
y compris sans l'accord du salarié lésé
l'article 6 bis doit permettre aux
organisations syndicales représentatif
d'ester en justice en faveur du salarié
détaché ou en cas de travail dissimulé
devant le conseil des prud'hommes sans
avoir à justifier d'un modèle
d'intéresser à condition que l'intéressé
ne s'y soit pas opposé
ce disposition me semble justifier sur
le plan éthique ans vont le met très
approximatives sur le plan
constitutionnel monsieur le ministre je
pense que dans votre for intérieur
vous souscrivez le principe selon lequel
nul ne peut plaider par procureur
principe qui est une sous catégorie du
principe de sécurité juridique ne me
semble pas respecté par ses deux
articles nous invitons donc la majorité
le gouvernement a affiné leur dispositif
autre exemple de dispositions justifié
sur le plan éthique l'article 7 bis
cet article instaure une nouvelle peine
pour les entreprises condamné pour
travail dissimulé à savoir l'exclusion
de toute aide publique pendant une
période de cinq ans nous comprenons le
caractère symbolique de la mesure
cependant nous craignons que celle ci
met en danger les salariés nam de
l'entreprise et en cas de reprise les
futurs repreneurs qui devront payer pour
autrui là encore ce sont les salariés
qui paieront et je doute que cela soit
votre volonté intime enfin ce sera notre
dernière interrogation celle ci est de
forme nous nous interrogeons sur le
caractère cavaliers de votre nouvel
article 9 qui vise à créer l'obligation
pour les employeurs de veiller à ce que
leur poids de madère des conducteurs
routiers soit pris dans les conditions
énoncées par les règles européennes
la somme de ces imprécisions nous
conduit donc à juger ce texte avec la
plus grande prudence
alors même que de nombreuses
dispositions peuvent trouver un écho
favorable dans notre groupe nous sommes
par exemple en accord avec l'article 1er
qui prévoit que toute entreprise
bénéficiaire d'une prestation
internationale doit vérifier que
l'entreprise prestataire établis hors de
france avec laquelle elles contractent
des pauses bien une déclaration de
détachement auprès des services de
l'inspection du travail nous souscrivons
également à l'article 4 sur
l'habilitation de l'inspection du
travail a du travail à exiger la
production immédiates de documents
propres au détachement des travailleurs
nous nous réjouissons par ailleurs de la
suppression de l'article 5 qui portait
sur les sanctions en cas de poursuite
d'activité avec un partenaire en
situation irrégulière nous ce dont nous
sommes donc quelque peu déçu par la
somme de ces approximations
car je le répète comme je l'aï dit en
préambule tout à l'heure ce texte était
est le bienvenu nous souscrivons à son
esprit un nombre de mesures des mesures
qu'il comporte malheureusement
l'applicabilité de l'extension de la
responsabilité solidaire la liste noire
des entreprises condamnées pour
travailler légal et l'extension du droit
d'agir en justice pour les syndicats ne
nous permettent pas je le dis très
clairement de voter favorablement à
l'endroit de ce texte et je me permets
puisque c'est la fin de mon intervention
de rappeler deux choses la première
can c'est la pertinence de ces deux
directives la directive bolkenstein la
directive détachement des travailleurs
si si et c'est très logique monsieur des
essarts vous ne m'entendez pas
suffisamment sur ce sujet là comme s'ils
ont beaucoup d'autres d'ailleurs comme
sur beaucoup d'autres d'ailleurs
ce sont deux directives particulièrement
pertinente mais elles ont été je dirais
qu'on tournait et ce texte vise à
corriger cela c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me suis jamais je dirais
privé de dire que l'accord du 9 décembre
et était un bon accord un premier accord
et que
nous ne sommes pas assez nombreux sur
tous les bancs de cette assemblée pour
dénoncer la démagogie et le populisme
qui entourent précisément les propos au
travers de ces deux directives parce que
l'objectif de ces deux directives c'est
d'arriver à créer un marché unique qui
est précisément à la clé est au coeur de
la croissance et du développement de
l'union européenne à cela j'ajouterai
bien évidemment le développement
numérique au sein même de toutes nos
entreprises ça c'est le premier point
que je tenais à souligner le deuxième
point monsieur le ministre
je voudrais vous avouer ma déception
car hier nous avons une discussion sur
le la ppl fonction de loi le roux sur
les ogm proposition loi totalement anti
constitutionnelle qui a été voté je
dirais par une majorité de cette
assemblée et là vous nous remettez un
texte pour partie portant des
dispositions que nous considérons
anticonstitutionnel cder l'article 6 et
demi l article 7 ce ministre je voudrais
vous rendre justice je ne pense pas du
tout que ce soit la résultante d'une
erreur d' analyse de vos services
c'est tout simplement pour moi le fruit
d'une posture politique est là à mon
avis ce n'est pas digne du sénat de
procéder ainsi de nous instrumentaliser
ainsi voilà c'est la raison pour
laquelle si vous voulez non sans regret
nous nous orientons vers l'abstention je
vous remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est maintenant monsieur jean
marie vanlerenberghe pour le groupe udi
uc
chez le président sur le ministre mes
chers collègues
cela a été dit le présent texte est
extrêmement technique mais il ne l'est
pas uniquement parce qu'il touche au
coeur de l'une des questions les plus
cruciales
posés par la construction européenne
celle de savoir comment articuler le
marché unique on vient de le dire avec
l'extraordinaire disparités de
législation sociale en vigueur dans les
pays membres
la libre circulation des travailleurs
est en effet inhérente au marché unique
avec la libre circulation des biens des
services et des capitaux
il est donc essentiel de réaffirmer
comme l'a très bien fait notre
rapporteur que le détachement des
travailleurs n'est pas synonyme de
travail illégal en revanche en l'absence
d'un cadre législatif européen
et national à la fois adapté cohérent et
ferme
effectivement le détachement est source
d'inégalités et il le sera tant que les
législations sociales ne seront pas
harmonisés aujourd'hui ce cadre est à
l'évidence insuffisant
aussi difficile et à établir et
approximatif
soit ils les chiffres demeurent éloquent
jean desessard et a rappelé entre 200000
et 300 mille salariés détachés non
déclarés sur le territoire français en
2009 et en 2010 cela bien sûr n'est pas
acceptable
alors pour faire face à cette situation
la législation européenne se durcit la
nôtre aussi et nous ne pouvons que nous
en féliciter le fait que les deux se
fasse de conserve ses fortes appréciable
appréciable que pour une fois monsieur
le ministre nous ne soyons pas en retard
pour transcrire une directive vous l'a
souvent rappelé ici au sénat
appréciable aussi pouvoir constater que
contre tous les stéréotypes dans une
matière par nature communautaire la
france conserve tout de même une marge
de manoeuvres juridiques certes étroite
et soumise au contrôle de la commission
mais tout de même réel ce qui m'amène au
fond en commençant par la fin une fois
n'est pas coutume pour me concentrer
ensuite bien sûr sur le coeur du texte
la face sont les dispositions relatives
au cabotage qui vont dans le bon sens
l'article 10 qui supprime l'obligation
faite aux transporteurs de marchandises
par route d'avoir une licence
communautaire pour faire du cabotage
était attendue des transporteurs
routiers français qui subissent une
concurrence déloyale des moines 3 tonnes
5 étrangers
de même on ne peut que soutenir
l'article 9 qui apporte des garanties
élémentaires en matière de repos
hebdomadaire et de pratiques de
rémunération dangereuse le texte
renforce aussi le droit français contre
le travail illégal
nous ne pouvons que soutenir les
dispositions qui obligent maître
d'ouvragé donneurs d'ordres à vérifier
que tous les sous traitants respecte les
droits du noyau dur garantie par la
législation européenne aux travailleurs
étrangers détacher ce texte les oblige
aussi à prendre en charge l'hébergement
collectif des salariés en cas
d'hébergement indignes voilà
d'excellentes mesures
de plus l'extension de la solidarité
financière à tous les cons contractant
du maître d'ouvragé du donneur d'ordres
est de nature à dissuader un peu plus le
travail dissimulé
mais le coeur du texte réside dans les
articles 1 et 2 ont là soulignait qui
transpose les les articles 9 et 12 de la
directive sur ces articles je tiens à
saluer le travail de simplification
effectuées par notre rapporteur
qui a très opportunément découpler la
déclaration préalable de détachement et
la question de solidarité financière en
vertu de cette nouvelle rédaction donc
l'article 1er oblige le prestataire à
déclarer préalablement le détachement
auprès de l'inspection du travail est le
donneur d'ordre ou le maître d'ouvragé à
vérifier que la déclaration vient été
fait et le non respect vous l'avez
souligné tout à l'heure le non-respect
de ces obligations expose à des
sanctions administratives
horde est dorénavant la solidarité
financière en cas de non paiement des
salariés renvoyés à l'article 2 ne
distingue plus qui s'ils sont détachés
ou non
donc voilà des dispositifs et un système
qui nous apparaît clair et qui appelle
notre soutien plein et entier celui de
nous
mais lorsqu'on a établi ces règles at on
réellement ce ministre était du problème
du détachement à sa racine
certainement pas parce que sa source
réside dans le fait que le travailleurs
détachés reste affilié au régime de
sécurité sociale de son pays d'origine
si le détachement du juan deux ans
et c'est bien cela qui explique
l'explosion du nombre de travailleurs
détachés dans notre pays les chiffres
donnés par notre rapporteur en atteste
22 fois plus de salariés détachés en
france en 2012 qu'en l'an 2000
l'équivalent de 25 mille
plutôt l'équivalent oui de 25000 e tp
sur une année
à l'heure où l'objectif du gouvernement
est d'inverser la courbe du chômage faut
se poser la question
qu'est ce qui peut bien motiver ces
détachements si ce n'est principalement
à différentiel de charges sociales qui
peut faire économiser on l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure
20 à 30% des salaires compte tenu de
cette distorsion les entreprises
françaises sont bien sûr inciter
financièrement à sous traiter
à des travailleurs étrangers détachées
or le problème n'est absolument pas
abordée par ce texte ni par la directive
et c'est une conséquence bien sûr pour
le texte comme s'il ne s'attaquer qu'aux
symptômes et pour combattre le vin à
terme monsieur le ministre il faudra
bien harmoniser vous l'avez rappelé tout
à l'heure les droits sociaux des pays
membres de l'union en particulier les
droits de la sécurité sociale
c'est d'ailleurs le pari fait par les
vrais européens
enclencher un cercle vertueux qui via le
marché unique conduira au rattrapage des
pays les moins développés et enfin à une
réalisation par le haut des niveaux de
vie et de la protection sociale ce pari
d'ailleurs certains le jugent impossible
or il avait déjà été gagnés avec les
pays du sud qui les premiers nous ont
rejoints dans la construction
communautaire je rappelle dans les
années 80 il est aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre
dans presque tous les pays dirons-nous
de l'est de l'europe mais on le sait le
processus sera encore long alors en
attendant la solution de transition qui
est envisageable
et qui figure d'ailleurs dans le
programme de l'udps élus du modem pour
les européennes c'est tout simplement de
soumettre les travailleurs détachés aux
cotisations sociales du pays d'accueil
et d'organiser les transferts des droits
y afférant dans le pays d'origine
monsieur le ministre
je vous pose une question cette solution
est elle à l'étude à l'échelon européen
et la france ne peut-elle pas pesé du
poids qui est le sien au sein de l'union
pour aboutir le plus rapidement possible
à sa mise en oeuvre voici deux questions
clés auxquelles
notre groupe attend des réponses ne me
reste plus pour conclure qu'à féliciter
madame
anne emery dumas pour l'excellence de
son travail et en particulier son effort
de pédagogie sur un texte qui est
particulièrement ardue techniquement
merci de votre attention
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur éric bocquet
pour le groupe crc
eh bien monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre le rapporter à présent de la
commission mes chers collègues alors que
le 16 avril dernier le parlement
européen a adopté la directive
d'applications sur le détachement des
travailleurs
l'assemblée nationale a adopté la
proposition qui nous est soumise
aujourd'hui qui a vocation en quelque
sorte à anticiper cette directive la
volonté légitime du gouvernement de ne
pas attendre l'adoption d'un projet de
directive ayant fait l'objet d'une
première fois d'un carton jaune par les
députés du parlement européen est
légitime et les mêmes compréhensible
tant la question du détachement des
travailleurs européens et le dumping
social du gnr inquiète nos concitoyens
pour autant anticiper n'est pas
nécessairement innover et d'aucuns
considèrent déjà et nous en sommes à
l'image du juriste hervé guichaoua que
cette proposition de loi comme la
directive européenne d'ailleurs est
insuffisante pour être réellement
efficace et pour cause cette proposition
de loi que la directive d'exécution ne
constitue en rien une remise en cause la
directive de 1996 c'est d'être rappelé
par nos collègues vanlerenberghe et la
finalité de cette dernière à savoir
organiser la concurrence des
travailleurs entre demeure c'est ainsi
que chaque année entre 200000 et 300
mille salariés venus d'autres pays
membres de l'union européenne viennent
travailler en france pour des salaires
inférieurs à ceux perçus par les
salariés nationaux mais surtout aux
cotisations sociales nettement inférieur
la différence cela a été rappelé
également peut-être importante elle peut
atteindre voire dépasser 30% c'est donc
un véritable dumping social que l'europe
organise que la directive d'exécution et
que cette proposition de loi encadre
sans pour autant jamais la remettre en
cause
c'est une directive en sorte
perdant-perdant dont les seuls gagnants
sont certains employeurs peu scrupuleux
ceux là même qui parfois aujourd'hui
existe du gouvernement encore plus de
cadeaux encore moins d'impôts encore
moins de cotisations sociales et la
question que nous sommes amenés à nous
poser aujourd'hui en examinant cette
proposition de loi est simple est-ce que
celle ci sera de nature à remédier à
cette situation la réponse nous laisse
un peu perplexe puisque la directive de
1996 demeure en l'état et il y a
quelques années à l'initiative notre
collègue catherine tasca notre haute
assemblée avait eu à débattre d'une
proposition beaucoup plus audacieuse
prenant la forme d'une proposition de
résolution qui demandait au gouvernement
la révision de la directive de 1996 et
la modif d'une modification des traités
ainsi la proposition de loi prévoit tel
de responsabiliser le donneur d'ordres
dans le cas où l'employeur du salarié
appliquerait à ce dernier une
rémunération inférieure à celle prévue
par la loi bien évidemment cette mesure
est positive il faut le souligner pour
autant que l'on accepte ce qui n'est pas
notre cas que la concurrence entre
travailleurs européens puissent
continuer à s'organiser via le
différentiel des cotisations sociales
mais ce n'est pas notre seule critique
en la matière puisque la proposition de
loi se contente de rappeler que le
travail allait tâcher doit être rémunéré
au smic or certaines entreprises ayant
recours ponctuellement à des
travailleurs détachés ou certaines
conventions de branches prévoient pour
les salariés du pays des rémunération
supérieure au smic sur ce point la
proposition de loi est silencieuse de
telle sorte que la concurrence entre
salariés français et salariés détachés
pourra également se faire à la fois sur
les cotisations mais aussi sur la
rémunération versée aux salariés
d'autant que cette proposition de loi
demeure également silencieux sur une
autre fraude massivement pratiquer et
qui consiste pour les employeurs parfois
à déduire du salaire qu'ils versent des
sommes exorbitantes au titre des frais
de logement de transport ou
d'alimentation dont il assume parfois
théoriquement la charge naturellement en
la matière les contrôles de
l'administration du travail seront
indispensables mais sans doute aurait-il
fallu explicitement visé ces cas pour
renforcer les sanctions
sans doute faudrait-il aussi monsieur le
ministre confortés réellement
l'inspection du travail en renforçant
ses effectifs reconnu comme trop faible
par nombre de commentateurs et
al'inverse des mesures réglementaires
prises par votre gouvernement renforcer
leur indépendance par ailleurs la
proposition entend également lutter
contre ce que l'on appelle des
entreprises boîte aux lettres et qui
constitue en la matière un véritable
fléau avec mes collègues du groupe crc
nous souscrivons pleinement à cet
objectif même s'il nous semble qu'il
aurait été possible d'aller beaucoup
plus loin nous formulons d'ailleurs une
proposition d'amendement en ce sens
précisant qu'un salarié ne peut jamais
être placé en situation de détachement
dans son pays d'origine cette précision
de semble être de nature à éviter
certains abus
les entreprises parvenant à concilier un
haut niveau de formation des compétences
des qualifications est très faible
rémunération
autre faiblesse que nous notons nous
aurions souhaité un net renforcement des
sanctions à l'encontre des employeurs
qui ne respecteraient pas les règles
sociales déjà très légère disant cela je
vise explicitement le non paiement des
cotisations sociales à l'urssaf et à
pôle emploi de tels cas il nous est
apparu souhaitable que la loi puisse
prévoir un mécanisme d'information à
destination du donneur d'ordre charge à
lui d'obtenir et de transmettre la
preuve que son sous traitant a
effectivement régulariser sa situation
dans le cas contraire l'entreprise
donneuse d'ordre aurait dû être tenu
responsable solidairement de cette
fraude vous le voyez mes chers collègues
nous réserve cette proposition de loi
sont assez importantes elles le sont
d'autant plus et nous sommes opposés
depuis l'origine à la directive de 1996
pour autant le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen agira à cette
proposition de loi comme chaque fois de
manière responsable et bien que nous
puissions considérer qu'elles manquent
parfois de vigueur et que le constitue
pas réellement la remise en cause que
nous espérions du dumping social
européen organisé par la directive nous
ne dirons pas les progrès que cette
proposition de loi comporte dans un
autre domaine s'inspirant de ce qui
existe dans le domaine des transports
aériens une liste noire des personnes
morales ou physiques condamné pour des
infractions constitutive de travail
illégal a au moins 15000 euros damende
serait élaboré et publié sur internet
là encore la mesure est positive bien
que n'ayant en réalité qu'une portée
assez limité sans doute aurait-il été
plus efficace de prévoir qu'une
entreprise inscrite dans cette liste ou
que les dirigeants de l'entreprise
inscrit dans cette liste noire ne soient
plus autorisées à détacher de
travailleurs en france pour le moins ces
entreprises devraient être
automatiquement privé de la possibilité
de répondre à des marchés publics voilà
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
en substance les critiques les remarques
et insuffisances que nous pouvions
formulé cette proposition de loi
laquelle apporte toutefois des garanties
nouvelles modeste mais réelle pour les
salariés c'est pourquoi le groupe crc
votre à en faveur de cette dernière
désireux que nous sommes de protéger les
salariés même partiellement et c'est
aussi dans notre esprit une forme
d'encouragement à aller beaucoup plus
loin ici en france comme à bruxelles
pour ouvrir enfin le chantier de
l'harmonisation sociale au sein de
l'union européenne journal
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame françoise laborde
pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le traité
de rome de 1957 qui visait à poser les
fondements d'une union sans cesse plus
étroite entre les peuples européens a
consacré la libre circulation des
personnes des marchandises des services
et des capitaux
cela signifiait notamment qu'un
prestataire de services établis dans un
pays de l'union européenne avaient le
droit de détacher temporairement des
travailleurs dans un autre pays membre
pour y accomplir une mission complexe
si ce droit aux frais un plus grand
choix de prestataires et pouvait
répondre à une éventuelle pénurie de
main d'oeuvre dans certains secteurs
bien précis
il n'en reste pas moins qu'il a ouvert
la voie à l'optimisation social au
dumping social
le 17 février
1894 devant l'assemblée nationale jean
jaurès déclarait ce que nous ne voulons
pas c'est que le capitalisme
international aille chercher la main
d'oeuvre sur les marchés où elle est le
plus à villy humilié déprécier pour la
jeter sans contrôle et sans
réglementation sur le marché français et
pourra mener partout dans le monde les
salaires au niveau des pays où ils sont
le plus bas
ce genre ce que jean jaurès redoutait il
ya 120 ans s'est malheureusement produit
nos salariés ont été confrontés à la
concurrence déloyale de prestataires de
pays dans lesquels les règles de protest
de protection des travailleurs sont
beaucoup moins exigeante et certains
employeurs y ont vu une occasion d'avoir
de la main d'oeuvre bon marché
avec la crise économique le mouvement
s'est amplifié
selon l'excellent rapport de notre
collègue guérir éric bocquet le
travailleurs détachés un saladier low
cost le nombre de travailleurs détachés
à augmenter de 45% depuis 2004 pour
mettre un terme aux dérives de dancing
sociale la directive européenne de 1996
relative au détachement de travailleurs
devait concilier l'exercice de la
liberté de fournir des services
transfrontaliers et la protection
appropriée des droits des travailleurs
détachés temporairement à l'étranger à
cet effet elle établissait ainsi un
socle de conditions de travail et
d'emploi imposé aux prestataires de
services dans le pays d'accueil pour
garantir une protection minimale des
travailleurs la cour de justice
européenne a toutefois quelque peu
ébranlée cet édifice protecteur selon la
jurisprudence exprimés par lacourt dans
quatre arrêts rendus entre 2007 et 2008
les droits fondamentaux étaient
susceptibles de subir des restrictions
et des limitations elle a ainsi
privilégié les libertés économiques
garanti par les traités et privé la
directive détachement des moyens
d'atteindre son objectif de protection
des salariés détachés le constat est
sans appel les principes édictés par la
directive de 1996 sont quotidiennement
bafoués par des entreprises sans
scrupules au point que certains ont
parlé de l'émergence d'un nouvel
esclaves modernes
les travailleurs parle rarement de la
langue du pays dans lequel ils sont
détachés ignore le draw leurs droits et
sont parfois contraints de dormir dans
des hangars et sur une simple paillasse
et certaines entreprises n'hésitent pas
à facturer à leurs salariés les frais
d'hébergement et de nourriture pour
compenser les salaires versés en france
plusieurs bilans effectués par la
commission européenne et les services de
contrôles nationaux ont régulièrement
dénoncé les détournements de la
directive et les très nombreux cas de
fraude en 2012 on estimait ainsi à 300
350 mille le nombre de travailleurs
détachés en france
170 mille étangs officiellement déclaré
s'il représente moins de 2% de la
population active
force est de constater que leur forte
concentration
notamment dans les métiers du bâtiment
de l'agriculture et des transports met
en péril nos entreprises notamment les
plus petites déjà fortement affecté par
la crise économique
la législation européenne en la matière
est devenue insuffisante voire
inefficace pire elle est devenue un
véritable outil de concurrence déloyale
qui déstabilisent des pans entiers de
l'économie française et l'absence de
dispositions concrètes en matière de
contrôle participe pleinement à
l'explosion de la fraude au détachement
ces abus ont conduit la commission
européenne en mars 2012 a présenté une
proposition de directive d'exécution je
tiens à ce titre a salué l'engagement du
gouvernement français qui a enfin permis
de trouver un compromis lors de la
réunion du conseil emploi politique
sociale santé et consommateurs du 9
décembre dernier le texte initial
n'était en effet pas acceptable est
constitué à véritablement une régression
pour notre pays la détermination dont a
fait preuve michel sapin a permis aux
états membres de s'entendre sur un
accord globalement satisfaisant pour la
france
aujourd'hui nous est proposé de
transposer cette directive d'exécution
adopté le 16 avril dernier par le
parlement européen il s'agit de mettre
en place les outils nécessaires pour
prévenir et sanctionner le dumping
social notamment en impliquant la
responsabilité du donneur d'ordre et du
maître d'ouvragé
nous ne pouvons donc que saluer
l'initiative de nos collègues
socialistes de l'assemblée nationale
cette proposition de loi devrait en
effet permettre d'endiguer les fraudes
de donner aux corps de contrôle un
ensemble de règles visant à la fois à
améliorer leurs informations des
situations observables sur le terrain
d'orienter leur contrôle et de renforcer
le caractère dissuasif des sanctions
encourues par les contrevenants
je pense notamment la possibilité de
poursuivre un donneur d'ordre d'ordre
pour les fraudes relevant d'un de ses
sous-traitants
au renforcement des pénalités pour les
infractions de travail illégal commises
en bande organisée ou encore à la mise
en place d'une liste noire sur internet
où figureront les entreprises qui auront
été condamné à une amende de plus de
15000 euros pour travail illégal sur ce
point nous vous proposerons d'ailleurs
que l'inscription sur cette liste noire
puisse se faire quel que soit le montant
de l'amendé les modifications apportées
tant par l'assemblée nationale que par
notre commission des affaires sociales
vont dans le bon sens et nous y
souscrivons pleinement pour autant comme
l'a rappelé la rapporteure dont je salue
l'excellent travail cette proposition de
loi ne suffira pas à elle seule à lutter
contre les abus liés au détachement des
travailleurs il faudra mettre en place
une véritable harmonisation sociale et
mettre fin à la dichotomie qui existe
entre les règles relatives à la sécurité
sociale et celles qui portent sur le
droit du travail en cas de détachement
en france nous devrons également
renforcer la coopération entre les
différents agents de contrôle améliorer
la réponse pénale et utiliser davantage
les sanctions administratives
pour toutes ces raisons les sénateurs du
rdse apporteront leur soutien à la
proposition de loi je vous remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame catherine
génisson pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente madame la
rapporteure mes chers collègues nous
sommes réunis pour examiner la
proposition de loi visant à lutter
contre la fraude et les abus constatés
lors des détachements des travailleurs
et la concurrence déloyale
j'intègre l' amendement modifiant le
titre de cette proposition de loi que
vous nous avez à juste titre proposé
madame la rapporteure en commission des
affaires sociales amendements votés qui
réaffirme l'essence même de ce texte
quand l'emploi est la première des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens
madame la rapporteure je veux saluer la
qualité de votre travail sur ce sujet
dont les dispositions peuvent paraître
très technique mais quand elles sont
éminemment politique
permettez moi aussi de remercier
chaleureusement notre collègue éric
bocquet auteur d'un rapport
d'information sur les normes européennes
en matière de détachement des
travailleurs et d'une proposition de
résolution adoptée au sénat le 16
octobre dernier ces travaux permettent
de nous éclairer sur la situation exacte
des travailleurs détachés et sur les
décisions qu'il convient de prendre pour
que soit respectée la dignité de leurs
conditions de travail
nous refusons l'europe de la coop est de
la compétition des travailleurs de la
guerre civile des droits sociaux
l'europe où la pauvreté des uns fait le
malheur des autres une europe qui serait
inéluctablement voué à s'abîmer dans le
rejet de nos peuples et dans les pires
événements populiste ainsi s'exprime et
gilles savary rapporteur du texte à
l'assemblée nationale lors de son examen
en séance publique le 18 février 2014
propos essentiel quand il s'agit de
transposer la directive 96 71 100e
adoptée en 1996 par l'union européenne
et applications largement contournée
depuis ça a été largement évoquée aussi
l'union européenne à proposer une
directive d'exécution pour en déterminer
les règles actuelles directive votée par
le parlement européen le 16 avril
dernier à
près de fortes discussions et d'ailleurs
de beaucoup d'oppositions entre les
différents états membres discussions qui
se sont conclues par un accord politique
obtenu au conseil des ministres le 9
décembre dernier grâce en particulier à
la détermination du gouvernement
français vous l'avez rappelé merci
monsieur le ministre
en effet quelle est la situation
actuelle à laquelle il convient de
palier des travailleurs détachés
salariés ou non exécutent leur travail
pour une pendant une période limitée sur
le territoire membres sera un territoire
membre autre que celui de leurs de leur
lieu de travail habituel les règles du
droit du travail sont celles du pays
d'accueil et sont regroupées au sein de
ce que l'on dénomme le noyau dire je ne
rappelle pas la teneur cela a été
largement développée lors des
interventions précédentes mais je veux
souligner disposition source de
distorsions sociales mais pour autant
aujourd'hui légale celle concernant le
régime de protection sociale en effet le
travail en détacher reste affilié au
régime de sécurité sociale de son pays
d'origine si le détachement dure moins
de deux ans ainsi à c'est leur
équivalent pour une entreprise le coût
d'un travailleurs détachés peut être
inférieure d'au moins 30% à celui d'un
travailleur exerçant en france
force est de constater que le texte que
nous examinons ce jour n'apporte pas de
réponse à cette question ô combien
fondamentale et j'y reviendrai
nous devons acté que le nombre de
travailleurs détachés a considérablement
augmenté ces dernières années
officiellement 38 milles à 270 milles à
170 mille pardons entre 2006 et 2012 en
réalité semble utile de 120000 à 300
milles à ce jour l'importance de la
fourchette objectivant la difficulté de
des pouvoirs publics d'en mesurer
l'exactitude
cette explosion quantitative du nombre
des détachements s'est accompagnée d'une
forte hausse d'abus et de fraude constat
que vous avez largement développé madame
la rapporteure comme beaucoup d'autres
d'intervenants un taux de déclaration
moyens à seulement 2 33 50 % des
entreprises prestataires coquille vide
le non respect du salaire du pays
d'accueil infractions parfois doublés
des lits du droit du travail sont les
constats les plus fréquents
infractions généralement caractérisé par
des montages juridiques très complexe
rendant les contrôles particulièrement
difficile à réaliser
s'il n'est pas de question de
stigmatiser le principe du détachement
rappelons d'ailleurs que près de trois
cent mille français travaillent à
l'étranger ce chiffre est d'ailleurs
difficile à objectiver la france est le
troisième pays derrière l'allemagne et
la pologne pour ces travailleurs
détachés mais pour nos entreprises pour
les travailleurs détachés nous avons le
devoir d'être efficace quand cette
exigence s'est exprimée unanimement par
les organisations syndicales et les
organisations patronales les
organisations professionnelles les
inspecteurs du travail les dispositions
de cette proposition de loi obéissent un
triptyque simple dissuasion en amont
contrôler vigilance lors de la
prestation sanctions en aval
dès lors le texte que nous examinons
comporte quatre grands types d'une
nouvelle mesure
tout d'abord la définition
de responsabilisation solidaire du
donneur d'ordre ou du maître d ouvrage
et en fait c'est le coeur la mesure
phare de ce texte
l'alourdissement des sanctions
la possibilité d'ester en justice pour
les organisations syndicales afin de
permettre de poursuivre des infractions
constatées sans que les intéressés est
obligatoirement souhaité le faire céder
6 ces dispositions importantes elles et
certains s'interrogent sur sa validité
sa possibilité d'exécution mais force
est de reconnaître que dans le code du
travail ces dispositions existent déjà
ça a été dit d'ailleurs en particulier
quand on parle de discrimination quand
on parle de harcèlement dans le au
travail et je crois que cette
disposition est vraiment importante à
mettre en place car beaucoup de
travailleurs hésitent à comment dire
porter plainte personnellement et puis
enfin il existe des dispositions
catégorielles qui concerne entonne entre
autres le btp et l'encadrement du
cabotage routier des marchandises et
notre collègue éric bocquet travaillé
beaucoup sur ces questions là
ces dispositions ont largement est
explicitée par vous même madame la
rapporteure monsieur ministre et
beaucoup d'interventions précédente
nous avons eu un débat très intéressant
commission des affaires sociales qui a
permis d'objectiver une volonté partagée
de lutter contre les abus les fraudes
concernant concernant les travailleurs
détachés vous avez beaucoup insisté
madame le rapporteur sur la nécessité de
simplifier les règles en matière de
déclaration de détachement de solidarité
financière arguant que la simplicité
prête beaucoup moins prises ou
détournement et d'ailleurs nous vous
avez proposé la réécriture de l'article
un amendement qui a été voté par notre
commission et qui doit je pense donner
une lecture plus facile de l'application
de ce que nous souhaitons faire
vous avez aussi souligné madame la
rapporteure à juste titre et ce constat
est partagé par nous tous que cette
proposition de loi si importante soit
elle ne suffira pas à lutter contre les
abus liés au détachement des
travailleurs quand il est fondamental
d'améliorer la mobilisation sociale au
niveau européen et ainsi de mettre fin à
la dichotomie qui existe entre les
règles concernant il ya différence de
protection sociale et celle qui porte
sur le cas sur le ce qui porte sur le
droit du travail en cas de détachement
nous avons évoqué par exemple la
différence de charges patronales entre
la france et la pologne sur le btp mais
je crois qu'on pourrait donner de
multiples exemples ce sujet tout à fait
central et je pense qu'il doit donner
lieu à des échanges à des débats dans le
cadre de la campagne électorale des
élections européennes qui nous occupe
tous
monsieur le ministre madame le
rapporteur mes chers collègues je veux
souligner la qualité partagée de nos
débats à propos de cette proposition de
loi certes le sujet n'est pas clos je
viens de l'évoquer mais pour autant le
groupe socialiste votera avec
détermination ce texte merci
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur claude
jeannerot pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'emploi reste à l'évidence et pour
longtemps encore sans doute la première
préoccupation des français
or l'europe il faut bien le reconnaître
n'est pas toujours perçue par nos
concitoyens comme une alliée sur le
front de l'emploi j'avais d'ailleurs
interrogé monsieur le ministre votre
prédécesseur ici même
c'était le 13 janvier 2013 sur la
problématique des travailleurs détachés
et plus largement d'ailleurs sur
l'avenir d'une europe sociale source de
progrès de développement et d'emplois
pour tous
la directive du 16 décembre 1996 ça a
été longuement rappelé ici à cette
tribune au départ conçu comme
protectrice des différents marchés du
travail européen est devenu en fait un
outil d'optimisation du profit est un
outil de dumping social au détriment de
la protection des travailleurs
c'est d'ailleurs le constat fait par
deux résolution européenne il faut le
rappeler l'une adopté par l'assemblée
nationale le 11 juillet dernier l'autre
par notre assemblée le 16 octobre 2013
ces deux textes invitait également le
gouvernement à faire preuve de fermeté
lors des négociations à bruxelles
notamment concernant le renforcement de
la marge de manoeuvre des états membres
dans les procédures de contrôle et il
faut le dire michel sapin et thierry
repentin ont défendu avec beaucoup de
combativité
cette position devant les états membres
ce qui a permis de trouver un accord et
c'était le 9 décembre 2013 le parlement
européen dans la suite vous le savez
vient de voter le 16 avril dernier
le projet de directive d'exécution sur
les travailleurs détachés afin que soit
renforcé les contrôles et la
responsabilisation des entreprises
donneuses d'ordre vis-à-vis de leurs
sous traitants
l'accord doit être formellement
approuvée par le conseil des ministres
il s'agit donc mes chers collègues d'un
signal fort l'europe n'accepte pas la
fraude ou l'abus des règles applicables
au détriment des travailleurs détachés
la proposition de loi qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui est donc le fruit d'une
volonté politique portée jusqu'à
bruxelles cette volonté politique vise à
renforcer la protection juridique des
travailleurs détachés qui sont les
victimes des dévoiements de plus en plus
nombreux de la procédure de détachement
comme je l'évoquais
la directive du 16 décembre
1996 avait pour objet d'encadrer le
détachement de travailleurs dans le
cadre de prestations de services elle
indiqué en particulier qu'une entreprise
peut détacher provisoirement ses
salariés dans un autre état membre de
l'union européenne
l'employeur doit alors se conformer aux
conditions de travail de l'état membres
tels que le respect du temps de travail
ou encore le salaire minimum en revanche
cela a été dit les cotisations sociales
sont versés dans le pays d'origine est
calculé selon les règles nationales
cette réglementation a en pratique était
largement détournée créant des
situations inacceptables de dumping
social notre excellent collègue éric
bocquet avait d'ailleurs mis en exergue
l'émergence d'un salarié low cost le
site à bas coûts risquant de créer des
tensions sur le marché du travail en
effet dès lors pourquoi recruter un
salarié français quand on peut disposer
d'un salarié venant d'un autre état
membre et ainsi économiser 30 % sur la
masse salariale
de nombreuses sociétés d'intérim en
d'ailleurs choisi de s'implanter dans
les pays où les cotisations sociales
sont faibles ou ne disposant pas de
salaire minimum
les entreprises qui sous-traitent ont
aussi bien sur leur part de
responsabilité elles ne peuvent ignorer
totalement la situation des travailleurs
détachés au sein de leur entreprise on
sait aussi que certains secteurs sont
plus touchés que d'autres comme celui du
bâtiment ou des transports
en france et partout en europe le nombre
de travailleurs détachés ne cesse
d'augmenter cela a été largement
soulignée par les orateurs qui m'ont
précédé à cette tribune
l'insuffisance des dispositions de la
directive de 1996 explique cette
explosion de pratiques pernicieuse
constit consistant à contourner
sciemment la législation à des fins
d'optimisation sociale
ma collègue anne emery dumas rapporteur
sur ce texte pour la commission des
affaires sociales a parfaitement mis en
relief la complexité des situations
frauduleuse pouvant être liées aux
règles de détachement ou encore
constitutive de travail illégal les deux
types d'infractions pouvant d'un pouvant
d'ailleurs aussi coexister
cette proposition de loi a donc pour
objet de lutter contre les fraudes et
détournements massifs qui consiste à
utiliser
le négoce de main d'oeuvre bon marché
comme argument de concurrence et je cite
là l'exposé des motifs et ainsi mettre
fin à l'émergence de cet esclavage
moderne
elle prévoit la responsabilisation de
manière solidaire du donneur d'ordre et
du maître d'ouvragé c'est évidemment une
mesure centrale qui a pour corollaire où
l'avait noté un renforcement des
contrôles et une accentuation des
sanctions financières il faut souligner
et que dans un souci de simplification
la commission des affaires sociales du
sénat a retenu un dispositif unique de
solidarité financière applicable
donneurs d'ordres et aux maîtres
d'ouvragé en cas de non paiement du
salaire minimum un salarié d'un
sous-traitant qu'il soit d'ailleurs
détachées ou non son champ d'application
a été logiquement étendue aux
entreprises de travail temporaire
ce texte prévoit également
la possibilité d'ester en justice pour
les syndicats de salariés afin de
pouvoir faire constater les infractions
sans que les intéressés pour les raisons
que l'on peut deviner et l'obligation de
leur donner un mandat à doc enfin des
dispositions cela a été souligné
des dispositions spécifiques pour les
secteurs les plus touchés tels que le
bâtiment et les transports sont prévues
cette proposition de loi ont résumé et
comme le faisait justement remarquer
notre collègue rapporteur anne emery
dumas la traduction de la volonté
conjointe du gouvernement et du
parlement et je veux la cité de
construire une europe sociale à la
hauteur des attentes de nos concitoyens
dans laquelle le primat accordé à la
concurrence ne doit plus se faire au
détriment de la protection des droits
des travailleurs
c'est pourquoi mes chers collègues vous
l'avez noté cette proposition de loi est
certes importante mais elle ne consiste
t mais elle ne constitue à ce stade
qu'une étape et une étape seulement dans
notre ambition d'une europe sociale
forte et solidaire
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est un monsieur roland ries ce
pour le groupe socialiste
ce président c'est le ministre madame le
rapporteur madame la présidente de la
commission du cher collègue
la proposition de loi déposée à
l'assemblée nationale par nos collègues
socialistes qui vise donc à lutter
contre le dumping social et la
concurrence déloyale
et qui est soumise aujourd'hui à notre
examen est de mon point de vue une
formidable invitation
à nous emparer d'un sujet complètement
d'actualité d'une actualité brûlante à
savoir le détachement des travailleurs
au sein de l'union européenne qui s'est
développé de façon exponentielle
ce sujet est délicat brûlant aussi car
cette disposition
transformé aujourd'hui en une véritable
mise en concurrence généralisée des
travailleurs et les différents modèles
sociaux nourrit une certaine manière la
méfiance ou parfois le rejet d'une
frange croissante de la population
envers l'union européenne elle en
illustre aussi malheureusement les
impasses en dévoyant un principe noble
celui de la libre circulation des
personnes nécessaires à l'émergence
d'une véritable conscience européenne
sujet brûlant brûlant disait car loin
d'être une abstraction pour nos
concitoyens le principe du détachement
des travailleurs dans un pays tiers tout
en continuant à être affiliés au régime
de protection sociale de leur pays
d'origine fait chaque jour sentir ses
effets cette disposition européenne se
pose avec une acuité particulière dans
les zones frontalières mais aussi dans
le reste du pays je pense en particulier
évidemment à la région
qui est la mienne l'alsace et c'est
d'ailleurs précisément pour faire face à
ces inquiétudes de nos concitoyens sur
ce sujet que j'avais interpellé le 18
décembre 2012 ici même le ministre de
l'agriculture stéphane le foll sur le
contexte de distorsion de concurrence
dont souffrent les producteurs de fruits
et légumes français plus précisément des
producteurs frontaliers vis-à-vis de nos
voisins européens
et parmi les éléments de réponse du
ministre figure est déjà en bonne place
la question de la directive européenne
sur le détachement des travailleurs de
1996 et son processus de révision ou
plutôt d'application le ministre avait
en effet indiqué que la france soutenait
la refonte de cette directive afin de
remettre un peu d'ordre dans le marché
unique européen
voilà pour cette séance nous reviendrons
plus largement sur les enjeux de ce
texte à 19 heures mais tout de suite ses
preuves par 3 l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat qui reçoit
jean luc mélenchon co président du parti
de gauche à tout à l'heure